Okay, so here is the code for our class
Movie one more time, and now, I am really curious
in figuring out what happens behind the scenes when
I create the instance called avatar by providing these four
pieces of information. These, by the way, are the
movie's name, its story line, the link to the movie's
poster image, and the link to its YouTube URL.
By the way, the last two of these two things
are clearly not links or URLs. They sound
more like English phrases, and I did that because
there wasn't enough room on the screen for me to add the full URLs or links. So,
as soon as we run this line of
code, the init function gets called. Self, in that
case, is itself or the instance being created. Which
is avatar. The variable movie_title gets the correct value,
which is Avatar. The movie_storyline variable gets
the correct value. The poster_image gets the
correct value also. And finally, the trailer_youtube
gets the correct trailer YouTube link. Okay,
so far so good. Now, once init gets called and all of these four
arguments receive their appropriate values, all of
the variables that are associated with the instance
avatar, they get initialized appropriately. So, at this
point, if I say avatar.storyline, the program will print
out the correct value. Okay, so now, I'm going
to take a small step back and tie together
a few pieces of information that we've been
seeing. Here is our class Movie. And after defining
the class Movie, I created two of its instances,
toy_story and avatar. I could have created more instances,
but for now, I've just created these
two. Now, when I created these two instances,
what I was really doing behind the scenes, is I was setting aside space for
each instance. And within that space, each
instance had their own copy of variables. These
variables include title, storyline,
poster_image_url and trailer_youtube_url. Here
are toy_story's variables, and here are avatar's variables.
Now, because these variables are unique to each instance of class movie, these
variables are called instance variables. And that phrase, instance
variables, is another new word that I will add to our list of words.